Ich wusste wenig über ihn,
denn meine Eltern, v.a. mein Vater,
sprachen höchst ungern
über die Ereignisse vor,
während und nach der Revolution.
Ich erfuhr kaum etwas über ihr Leben
in Russland, in Pjatigorsk.
Eines Tages -
ich war vielleicht 16 -
stiess ich auf das Tagebuch
meines Urgrossvaters Michele.
Ich fing an zu lesen
und stellte mit Erstaunen fest,
dass er zu Beginn
der Russischen Revolution
die sozialen Umwälzungen
befürwortete
und sich davon
positive Veränderungen
in der russischen Gesellschaft
versprach.
Doch sehr bald merkte er, dass
nichts seinen Erwartungen entsprach.
Er entschloss sich für die Flucht,
denn das Leben der ganzen Familie
war ernsthaft gefährdet.
"Dieser Pass wurde uns
von der Schweizer Delegation
bei unserer Abreise ausgestellt."
"Ende September 1918."
- Hier sieht man sie alle drei.
Sie sind zusammen abgereist,
am 17. Oktober, glaube ich.
Im Oktober 1918 ging in Sankt
Petersburg alles drunter und drüber.
Nichts funktionierte mehr,
und sie erwischten noch
den zweitletzten Zug.
Einige Möbel
stellten sie in ein Möbeldepot,
andere überdeckten sie
mit grossen Tüchern.
Dann verschlossen sie die Wohnung
und übergaben die Schlüssel
den Nachbarn,
in der Annahme, dass sie
nach drei Wochen wieder zurückkämen.
Und am Schluss schreibt sie noch:
"Da sitzen wir nun
auf unseren Koffern,
die letzten Schweizer
von Sankt Petersburg."
"Um 9 Uhr morgens
mussten wir uns am Bahnhof einfinden
und nun warten wir seit Stunden
inmitten von Gehstöcken,
Regenschirmen, Toilettentaschen
und Proviantkörben -
neben uns Berge von Gepäck."
"Leise sprechen wir
über unsere baldige Rückkehr
in die liebgewonnene Wahlheimat,
in der Überzeugung,
dass der Spuk bald
vorbei sein wird."
Doch sie kehren nicht mehr zurück,
all die Schweizer,
die während Jahrzehnten
in Sankt Petersburg, Moskau
und anderen Städten gelebt haben,
wo ihnen Russland
im Zuge des Wachstums einmalige
Entwicklungschancen gewährt hatte.
Vor der Revolution lebten in Russland
rund 10'000 Schweizer.
Gut 8'000 flohen
zwischen Frühjahr und Herbst 1918,
nach der Machtübernahme
durch die Bolschewiken.
Aus den Tagebüchern und Briefen,
die sie hinterlassen haben,
spricht ihr Schmerz
über diesen Abschied.
Für die einen bedeutete
die Revolution das Ende der Welt,
wie es Germaine Kaufmann empfand,
für andere war sie willkommen
und öffnete neue Wege.
So sah es anfänglich auch
Michele Raggi aus Morcote.
* Kirchenglocken *
"Vor einem Jahr begann ich,
dieses Tagebuch zu schreiben."
"Bescheidene Aufzeichnungen
über die Ereignisse in einem Land,
das während 23 Jahren
unsere zweite Heimat war."
"Ungeheuerliche Ereignisse,
denen ich beigewohnt habe."
Kommt, Kinder!
Grossvater wartet auf uns.
"In meiner isolierten Lage
ist es mir natürlich nicht möglich,
eine vollständige Abhandlung
über die Russische Revolution
zu schreiben."
"Aber die
hier beschriebenen Vorkommnisse
können vielleicht erklären,
warum die anfänglich grossen Ideale
der Revolution
schliesslich von Fanatikern
und Radikalen verraten wurden."
* Düstere Musik *
* Mystischer Gesang *
"Die Extremisten
bemächtigten sich der Massen,
die sich gerade erst von ihrer
antiken Sklaverei befreit hatten."
"Sie haben die ehrwürdigen Worte
Freiheit, Gleichheit
und Brüderlichkeit missbraucht."
* Mystischer Gesang *
"Sie haben den Sozialismus ...
* Stöhnen *
... und den Internationalismus ...
... in der ganzen Welt entehrt."
* Mystischer Gesang *
Geht da rein
und wartet einen Augenblick.
Michele ...
Michele!
* Mystischer Gesang *
* Unverständliche
Lautsprecherdurchsage *
* Pfiff *
Der Zug hält hier nicht lange.
Wir bleiben nur kurze Zeit.
Mein Wunsch, nach Russland,
genauer, in den Kaukasus zu reisen,
entstand aus Neugier.
Ich wollte die Orte kennenlernen,
wo meine Familie
während gut 20 Jahren gelebt hatte.
Hier. Schau!
In 2 1/2 Std. haben wir gerade mal
diese kurze Strecke zurückgelegt.
Beim Lesen des Tagebuchs kam
die Idee und auch die Hoffnung auf,
noch irgendetwas zu finden,
das Aufschluss
über das geben könnte,
über das was meiner Familie widerfahren ist.
Und mit der Zeit dachte ich auch:
Wenn ich jetzt nicht gehe,
gehe ich nie mehr.
Ecco, Volgograd ...
1895 reisten vier Tessiner und vier
Italiener aus Como in den Kaukasus,
nachdem sie ihren ganzen Besitz
in der Heimat verkauft hatten.
Sie pachteten bei einem
russischen Prinzen 1'500 ha Land
und gründeten am Fusse des Kamelbergs
die Landwirtschaftskolonie
San Nicola.
Sie legten
Weinberge und Obstplantagen an,
führten
neue Techniken der Viehzucht ein
und bauten einen blühenden
Landwirtschaftsbetrieb auf,
der über 200 Bauern und Tagelöhnern
aus den umliegenden Dörfern
Arbeit gab.
An der Spitze der Kolonie
standen der Agronom Michele Raggi
und seine Frau
Angelica Kaufmann aus Luzern.
Mit der Oktoberrevolution von 1917
und dem darauffolgenden Bürgerkrieg
geriet das Leben in der
Landwirtschaftskolonie aus den Fugen.
Der Betrieb
wurde geplündert und zerstört,
die Besitzer zur überstürzten
Heimkehr in die Schweiz gezwungen.
Michele gelang es, seine Familie
in Morcote in Sicherheit zu bringen,
wo er wenige Tage nach der Ankunft
unerwartet starb.
* Ruhige Mandolinenklänge *
"Angelica, mein Engel."
"Ihre Stimme und ihre Anwesenheit
sind wie ein Licht im Dunkeln."
Leiser, Oskar.
Grossvater ist am Schreiben.
Wir sollten ihn nicht stören.
Ja, Mama.
Michele ...
Ich möchte nicht,
dass dich jemand sieht.
"Kamelberg, 20. September 1918."
"Wenn ich daran denke,
wie die Fanatiker
Russland in den Abgrund stürzen,
verspüre ich einen Schmerz, der sich
kaum in Worte fassen lässt."
"Die Gedanken schweifen zu den
Anfängen dieser Revolution zurück,
die aus Russland
ein neues, freies und
demokratisches Land machen wollte."
"Im Sog der Begeisterung jener Tage
erschien uns die Revolution
wie ein natürlicher,
unvermeidbarer Knall,
eine reife Frucht, deren Moment
gekommen war, vom Baum zu fallen."
"Es ist unverzeihlich,
dass das Volk so lange versklavt
und in Unwissenheit
gehalten worden ist."
* Aufwühlende Musik *
Nach ihrer Rückwanderung
lässt sich die Familie Kaufmann
im Waadtland nieder.
Die damals zwölfjährige
Germaine Kaufmann
wird sich zeitlebens an ihre Kindheit
in Sankt Petersburg erinnern
und teilt diese Erinnerungen
in ihren letzten Lebensjahren
immer wieder gern
mit ihren drei Enkelinnen.
Sankt Petersburg gehörte damals
zu den grossen
europäischen Hauptstädten.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
was es bedeutete,
das kleine Neuchatel
hinter sich zu lassen
und in diese strahlende Stadt
zu ziehen.
Zu jener Zeit stellten
die grossen Städte ihren Reichtum,
ihre Kultur und ihre Lebensfreude
gerne zur Schau.
Bestimmt waren sie überwältigt
von all dem Glanz und Licht.
Man darf nicht vergessen: Die
Schweiz war damals ein armes Land.
Viele wanderten aus,
um im Ausland Arbeit zu finden.
Mein Urgrossvater
stammte aus dem Kanton Neuchatel,
genau wie meine Urgrossmutter.
Doch kennengelernt haben sie sich im
Schweizerhaus in Sankt Petersburg.
Dort ist ihre Liebe geboren
und dort haben sie geheiratet.
Beide stammten
aus einfachen Verhältnissen.
Unsere Grossmutter
erinnerte sich sehr gut
an ihre Kindheit in Russland, wo sie
bis zur Revolution gelebt hatte.
Ich glaube, mit der Zeit hat sie
diese Erinnerungen etwas verklärt,
aber aus ihrer Sicht hatte sie alles
so erlebt, wie sie es erzählte.
Sie erzählte so intensiv,
dass ich als Kind glaubte,
wir seien eine russische Familie.
Ich hatte nicht begriffen,
dass ihre Eltern
aus Russland zurückgekehrt waren,
denn sie sprach,
als wäre alles noch so wie früher.
Wir schliefen im gleichen Zimmer
und morgens um 7 Uhr
durfte ich in ihr Bett schlüpfen,
und sie erzählte mir von Russland.
Sie besass auch einen Karton
voller Fotografien.
Als ich älter war, sagte ich zu ihr:
"Oma, wenn du
diese Fotos nicht einklebst
und deine Erinnerungen
nicht aufschreibst,
wird alles vergessen gehen,
wenn du nicht mehr da bist."
So setzte sie sich
eines Tages hin und begann,
die Fotos einzukleben
und zu schreiben.
* Sanft-melancholische Musik *
"3. Oktober 1918."
"Seit Monaten leben wir in dem
von den Sowjets besetzten Gebiet."
"Die von mir gegründete Schweizer
Kolonie existiert nicht mehr."
"Die Macht ist in den Händen
der Sowjets und der Komitees,
von denen täglich neue entstehen
und sich wieder auflösen."
"V.a. aber herrscht Terror."
"Plünderungen und Raubzüge
der Roten Garde und anderer Banden."
"Unser Land wurde beschlagnahmt
und an die Bauern und Taglöhner
verteilt."
"Jetzt sind alle Landbesitzer,
aber kaum einer arbeitet."
"Die Produktion ist eingebrochen,
viele Maschinen stehen still,
und das Land stürzt in den Ruin."
"Dabei hatte die Revolution
Freiheit gebracht."
"Es wehte ein neuer Wind, der
eine strahlende Zukunft versprach."
"Doch dann heizten die Demagogen
die Massen an
und schürten den Klassenhass."
* Mystischer Gesang *
"Was wird wohl aus diesem Land?"
"Was wird aus uns?"
Opa Michele. Die Mädchen
möchten Ihnen Gute Nacht sagen.
Gute Nacht, Grossvater.
- Gute Nacht, meine liebe Angelica.
Gute Nacht, Jeanne.
Bis später.
- Ja, mein Schatz.
Bis morgen.
"Der Winter steht vor der Tür.
Das macht mir Angst."
"Ich sorge mich um sie."
"Alles steht still,
und wir sind völlig isoliert."
"Es ist schrecklich,
dass wir diesen ausbrechenden Vulkan
nicht verlassen können."
Hallo, Renata und Michele,
ich komme euch kurz besuchen.
Wie geht's?
- Gut, danke. Bei euch?
Hast du etwas gegessen?
- Ja, Salat und Suppe.
Meine Tante erzählte, es genügte,
ein paar Kartoffelschalen
in die Erde zu stecken,
und schon wuchs daraus
eine Kartoffel.
Sie produzierten auch Wein,
und einige Tessiner und
Norditaliener waren Weinexperten.
Den verkauften sie u.a. an
der Weltausstellung in Mailand 1906.
Ich denke, meine Urgrosseltern haben
es in Russland zu etwas gebracht.
Sie waren bestimmt
sozial besser gestellt,
als wenn sie
in der Schweiz geblieben wären.
Unser Urgrossvater leitete das
Restaurant des Grand Hotel d'Europe.
Er hatte das gesamte Servicepersonal
und die Küchenbrigade unter sich.
Die Urgrossmutter
war nach Russland gereist,
um dort in einer reichen Familie
zu arbeiten.
Sie musste sich
um die Kinder kümmern
und ihnen Französisch beibringen.
Auch sie hatte also
eine ansehnliche Stelle.
Man sieht sie auf diesem Foto,
neben der Hausherrin,
als die Familie
Brot an die Leibeigenen verteilt.
Sie trägt keinen Hut, aber auch sie
verteilt Brot an die Armen.
Es liegt sicher auch an der
sozialen Stellung ihrer Eltern,
dass meine Grossmutter
dieses Leben in Russland
wie ein Eldorado in Erinnerung hat,
ein verlorenes Paradies.
* Beschwingte Musik, Wasserrauschen *
"10. Oktober 1918."
"Nichts kann uns mehr erschüttern,
nicht einmal
solch absurde Nachrichten, wie die,
die mir mein Sohn heute
überbracht hat."
"Da man sich nicht einigen konnte,
wie der Stall,
den ich vor wenigen Jahren
erbaut habe,
unter den zahlreichen Anwärtern
aufgeteilt werden soll,
wird er jetzt abgerissen."
"So bekommt jeder
ein paar Steine und Holzbretter."
Ist denn das die Möglichkeit?
So wurde es gestern an
der Generalversammlung beschlossen.
Zu viele wollten den Stall.
Gut macht ihr das. Gratuliere!
Wirklich sehr gut.
Wenn sie so weitermachen, werden sie
das ganze Land in den Ruin stürzen.
Stell dir vor,
die haben sogar applaudiert,
als der Abbruch beschlossen wurde.
Was für ein Unsinn!
Die früheren Herrscher
haben vieles falsch gemacht,
die Industriellen,
die Grossgrundbesitzer.
Aber so ... So ...
Wo führt das alles nur hin?
Gib mir den Koffer, Michele.
Danke.
Geht's?
Freut mich.
Freut mich. Ich bin Renata Raggi
aus der Schweiz.
Hallo, Elena.
Schön, Sie kennenzulernen.
Ganz meinerseits. Ich bin Ihr Guide
hier in Pjatigorsk.
Das ist unser Chauffeur, Gurgen.
Kann ich Ihnen helfen?
- Der ist nicht schwer.
Danke, auf Wiedersehen.
Sie hatten schlechtes Wetter?
- Nein, eigentlich nicht.
(Gurgen) Sprechen Sie Französisch?
- Ja.
Und Frau Pia spricht Russisch.
... dann wäre die Revolution
nicht gewesen.
Viele Leute haben alles verloren.
Oh, ja.
Viele haben ihr Leben verloren.
* Antreibende Musik *
Ein grossartiger Empfang.
* Alle lachen *
Schau mal, die Kinder!
Schau mal dort vorne!
Das haben wir vom Zug aus gesehen.
Wunderbar! Einmalig schön!
Wunderbar!
"Der unbekannte Soldat".
Schau dir das an!
Das ist ein Lenindenkmal.
Unter dem kommunistischen Regime
gab es in der Sowjetunion
insgesamt 7'000 Lenindenkmäler.
Während der Perestroika
sind jedoch viele zerstört worden.
6'000 Denkmäler
sind bis heute geblieben.
Von hier aus
sieht er die ganze Stadt.
* Sie spricht russisch. *
Wenn die Menschen
diese Treppe hochkommen,
schreiten sie sozusagen
ihrem Leader entgegen.
Herrlich, diese Aussicht.
Wo wohl der Kamelberg steht?
Rechts oder links von uns?
Wenn von der Revolution die Rede
ist, kommt mir immer in den Sinn,
dass unsere Grossmutter
Lenin kennengelernt hat.
Sie sagte: "Hätte ich gewusst,
wer Lenin wirklich war,
hätte ich ihn umgebracht!".
Sehr schön.
Sie sehen aus wie Kostüme.
Ja, die Kleidung
ist immer wieder anders.
Das war 1916.
Hier steht: "Beginn der Revolution".
An diesen Fotos kann man die nahende
Katastrophe beinahe erkennen.
Das war kurz vor der Flucht.
Hier sehen sie irgendwie
besorgt aus.
Plötzlich geht alles sehr schnell.
Bis dahin war alles wie im Paradies.
Eine heile Welt, die existierte.
Grossmutter schreibt z.B.:
"Wir gehen auf eine Insel,
in einer offenen Kalesche."
"Dort sehen wir
andere glückliche Menschen,
wie wir es sind."
Und dann wird es düster,
die Dinge ändern sich.
Aus den Anekdoten, die sie erzählt,
ist eine wachsende Unruhe zu spüren.
Z.B. das Gefühl, bei der Heimfahrt
in der Kalesche verfolgt zu werden.
Auch der Vater fürchtet sich,
wenn er nachts das Hotel verlässt.
Im Oktober zieht die Familie
ein erstes Mal um.
Dieser Umzug
leitet das Ende ihrer Kindheit ein.
Während die kindliche Unbeschwert-
heit vergeht, steigt die Besorgnis.
* Ein Pferd nähert sich. *
Guten Tag, meine Liebe.
Angelica, willkommen zu Hause!
- Die Reise war mühsam.
Die Weisse Armee
steht vor den Toren von Pjatigorsk.
Hoffen wir, dass der Krieg
nicht bis hierher vordringt.
Auch wenn sich die Lage
beruhigen sollte,
die Stimmung bleibt gedrückt.
Die Bolschewiki haben alle Zeitungen
ausser ihre geschlossen.
Und wir beklagten uns
über die Zensur unter dem Zar.
Und hast von der Kollektivierung
der Landwirtschaft gehört?
Aber ja.
Ein Hirngespinst, völlig utopisch!
Ausgerechnet jetzt,
wo die Bauern Land bekommen haben.
Erzählt denen
mal was von Kollektivierung!
Die lachen euch ins Gesicht.
Aber sie ist Teil
des kommunistischen Programms.
Es stimmt, Michele.
Sie sind verrückt. Total verrückt!
Wenn sie den Menschen
die Kollektivierung aufzwingen,
wird das in einem Blutbad enden.
Das führt
zur wirtschaftlichen Katastrophe.
Renata, wäre mein Vater
etwas aufgeschlossener gewesen
und hätte mir von früher erzählt,
wäre es anders gekommen.
Ganz bestimmt.
Wir halten kurz an
und kaufen Mineralwasser.
Ist in Ordnung.
Entschuldigen Sie.
Darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
Der Berg dort vorne,
ist das der Kamelberg?
Ja, das ist er.
- Und wie kommen wir dahin?
Gehen Sie diese Strasse entlang
und dort vorne führt ein Weg hinauf.
Hinauf?
Ja, aber seid vorsichtig.
Da gibt es Schlangen.
Vielen Dank, auf Wiedersehen.
Sie sagt, es gebe Schlangen.
Wir müssen vorsichtig sein.
* Muhen *
Schau, dort, Michele!
- Mamma mia, da ist der Kamelberg!
Könnten wir kurz anhalten,
um den Berg von Weitem zu sehen?
Ja, sobald ich
einen geeigneten Platz finde.
* Sanft-melancholische
Harmonika-Musik *
Schau, auch hier.
Dietz.
Jeanne Dietz.
Jeanne Dietz-Rohrbach. Das ist
deine Urgrossmutter, Michele.
Dietz ... Rohrbach. Unglaublich.
Dass der Grabstein noch steht.
- Das ist unglaubliches Glück.
Grabsteine wie diese, die aus
der Zeit vor der Revolution stammen,
wurden grösstenteils zerstört.
Deshalb finden so viele Leute
ihre Vorfahren nicht mehr.
Sie haben grosses Glück.
Sie sagt, dass fast alle Grabsteine
zerstört worden sind.
* Donnern *
"5. November 1918."
"Mit zittrigen Händen beschreibe ich
die heutigen Ereignisse."
"Eine Abteilung der Roten Armee
hat unsere Kolonie
geplündert und zerstört."
"Pure, schreckliche Gewalt."
"Eine Nachbarsfrau wurde erdrosselt,
mein Freund Edoardo Broggi
liegt im Sterben."
"Frauen und Kinder
konnten wir retten,
indem wir sie im Stall versteckten."
Draussen ist alles ruhig.
Oscar, du solltest schlafen gehen.
Wie geht es den Kindern?
Sie sind eingeschlafen,
aber sie haben Angst.
Ich werde mich noch einmal beim
Vorsitzenden des Sowjets beschweren.
Wie viele Plünderungen haben wir
nun schon erlitten, Michele?
Wie oft müssen wir noch zusehen,
wie Fanatiker und Betrunkene
aus blinder Wut alles zerstören,
was ihnen in die Hände kommt,
umbringen, wen sie wollen?
Wir können
nicht länger hierbleiben, Michele.
Wir können nicht warten,
bis es auch uns trifft.
Es reicht, Michele. Es reicht.
Bitte.
* Schluchzen *
Wir sollten vielleicht jemanden
finden, den wir fragen können.
* Klopfen, Bellen *
Guten Tag.
Unsere Gäste aus der Schweiz
suchen nach Informationen
über ihre Vorfahren, die hier
vor vielen Jahren gewohnt haben.
Von Schweizern weiss ich nichts.
Hier lebten Italiener.
Sie kamen
aus der italienischen Schweiz.
Aus der italienischen Schweiz?
Das war ihr Haus.
Es war eine ganze Familie.
Das Haus stand da hinten.
Es hiess Haus Raggi.
Das Haus Raggi stand da hinten?
Jetzt steht dort ein anderes Haus,
aber die Kellerräume sind geblieben.
Der Keller
gehört noch zum alten Haus Raggi.
Anstelle des Hauses der Raggi
steht jetzt ein anderes Haus.
Aber die Kellerräume
sind noch dieselben.
Darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
Warten Sie,
ich schalte den Motor aus.
Vor der Revolution gab es hier eine
schweizerisch-italienische Kolonie.
Wissen Sie etwas darüber?
Ja, die haben hier gelebt.
Sie hatten wunderschöne Rebberge.
Aber fragen Sie Alexandra Evgenevna!
Wo wohnt Alexandra?
Wenn Sie diese Strasse entlang-
gehen, werden Sie sie finden.
Vielen Dank.
- Gerne geschehen.
Hören Sie,
gehen Sie um das Dorf herum.
Dahinter lagen die Weinberge.
Diese Leute
hatten wunderschöne Weinberge.
Sie haben aus dem Nichts
zahlreiche Tätigkeiten aufgebaut.
Sie hatten verstanden, dass Wein-
reben in diesem Klima gut gedeihen.
Man lebte gut hier.
Sie brachten den Leuten viel Arbeit,
bis die Bolschewiki kamen.
Vielen Dank, auf Wiedersehen.
* Bellen *
Guten Tag!
Das sind unsere Gäste
aus der Schweiz.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Wunderbar!
Das hier, das ist Herr Raggi.
Das ist Herr Raggi?
- Das ist er.
Das ist mein Grossvater.
Bitte, kommt ins Haus!
Ich bin eine alte Dame und werde
rasch müde, wenn ich lange stehe.
Bitte, kommt herein.
Sie ist etwas alt
und bittet Sie, einzutreten.
Keine Angst vor den Hunden.
Valerio!
Valerio ist mein Mann.
Kannst du ihr sagen,
dass ich Fotos bei mir habe?
Die hier.
Unser Berg. Der Kamelberg.
Und das ist das grosse Haus.
Das wurde vollständig abgebrochen.
Das war ein Lagerhaus.
Und hier unten war der Keller.
Den gibt es noch.
* Pia übersetzt ins Italienische. *
Da, das hier ist der Weinkeller.
Und hier vorne
führte ein Weg hindurch.
Und das ist mein Vater.
Mio papa.
Auf dem Hof herrschte immer Ordnung.
Es war schön anzusehen.
Überall Blumen,
schön gepflegte Weinberge.
Der kommt aus Italien!
(Alexandra)
Der ist über 100 Jahre alt.
Es freut mich sehr, dass ich mich
in diesen Sessel setzen darf.
Den Sessel meiner Grossmutter
oder Urgrossmutter, wer weiss ...
Äusserst bequem.
Renata, schau!
Und hier ist noch eine Reliquie.
* Lachen *
Die Weinkellerei Raggi!
Ein Weinfass.
Praktisch in die Wand eingebaut.
Wie in Melide, genau wie in Melide.
Das ist einfach einzigartig.
Wunderbar!
"8. November 1918."
"Gestern haben wir
unsere geliebte Kolonie verlassen
und all unser Hab und Gut
zurückgelassen."
"Es war zu gefährlich geworden."
"Wilde Horden stürmten den
Weinkeller, um sich zu betrinken."
"Wir wohnen bei einer Familie
in einem Nachbardorf
und schlafen zu acht
in einem Zimmer,
aneinander gepfercht
wie die Sardinen."
"Unser einziges Ziel ist,
mit dem Leben davonzukommen."
Unser Urgrossvater hatte dem Direk-
tor des Hotel d'Europe versprochen,
dass er seine Stelle
nicht verlassen würde.
Eine Vorstellung
aus dem letzten Jahrhundert.
Er versprach seinem Patron
Treue bis zum letzten Augenblick.
Doch am Ende
stürmten die Bolschewiken
auch das Hotel d'Europe.
"Die Bolschewiki
besetzten das Hotel d'Europe,
verwüsteten die herrlichen Suiten,
in denen einst Persönlichkeiten
aus der ganzen Welt logiert hatten."
"Sie plünderten den Weinkeller
mit erstklassigen Weinen
und nahmen alles mit,
was ihnen in die Finger kam."
"Erst jetzt rief der Hoteldirektor
meinen Vater zu sich
und beiden war klar,
dass dies das Ende war."
"Da Vater dem Verwaltungsrat
des Hotels versprochen hatte,
dass er das Restaurant
bis zum Ende führen würde,
betrachtete er sich
von seiner Aufgabe erlöst
und reichte seine Kündigung ein."
Ich glaube,
es ist ihm überaus schwergefallen,
dieses Land zu verlassen.
Es muss ihm das Herz
zerrissen haben,
dieses Land aufgeben zu müssen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Mit etwa zehn Jahren hatte unsere
Grossmutter eine Blinddarmentzündung
und wurde operiert.
Der Arzt verschrieb ihr einen zwei-
wöchigen Genesungsurlaub am Meer.
Ein Kunde des Hotel d'Europe
empfahl den Eltern
ein kleines Hotel auf der Krim.
Natürlich hatte meine Grossmutter
den Fotoapparat dabei
und so entdeckte ich
zu meiner grossen Überraschung,
dass die Besitzer dieses Hotels
Raggi hiessen.
Meine Urgrossmutter
und meine Grossmutter
haben also zwei Wochen
in diesem Hotel gewohnt.
Es ist doch unglaublich, dass sie
so weit weg von Sankt Petersburg,
auf der Krim, ausgerechnet
bei Tessinern logierten.
* Sanfte Musik *
Der Zufall wollte also,
dass sich die Geschichte
der kleinen Germaine Kaufmann
nach ihrer Operation mit dem
Schicksal der Familie Raggi kreuzte.
In einem kleinen Hotel
in Eupatoria am Schwarzen Meer.
Niemand kannte das Hotel,
das die Raggis während mindestens
einem Sommer geführt haben.
Vielleicht sollte einer der Söhne
ins Hotelgeschäft einsteigen.
Aber dies sind reine Vermutungen.
Es war im Sommer 1916,
zweieinhalb Jahre vor der Flucht.
"31. Dezember 1918."
"Der letzte Tag
eines schrecklichen Jahres."
"Wir sind einer Frevlerbande
ausgeliefert."
"Leuten, die keinen Funken
Menschlichkeit in sich tragen,
noch sozialistische oder
kommunistische Ideale vertreten."
"Täglich hören wir sie sagen,
man müsse alle Bourgeois ausmerzen."
"So nennen sie uns, Bourgeois,
wo wir das ganze Leben
hart gearbeitet haben."
* Beschwingte Streichmusik *
"17. Januar 1919. Endlich frei!"
"Nach einer weiteren Nacht
voller Schrecken und Gewalt,
hat die Vorhut der einheimischen
Kavalleristen und Kadetten
die Sowjettruppen zurückgeschlagen."
"Die Freude über die Befreiung
ist unbeschreiblich."
"Unsere Befreier
sind Kavalleristen aus dem Kaukasus:
Kabardiner, Transkaukasier, Kosaken,
Tscherkessen aus dem Kuban."
"Nomadensoldaten,
die als Briganten bekannt sind."
"Ausgerechnet sie erlösen uns von
der gehassten und grausamen Tyrannei
der russischen
sozialistischen Anarchie."
"20. Januar 1919.
Adieu, mein Kamelberg."
"Wir haben beschlossen,
noch heute Nacht zu fahren."
"Sollten die Sowjets
diese Region erneut besetzen,
wären wir völlig verloren."
"Der Kommandant der Kadettentruppe
lässt uns nach Noworossijsk
am Schwarzen Meer fahren,
wo wir vielleicht ein Schiff finden,
mit dem wir Russland
verlassen können."
"23. Januar 1919."
"Seit zwei Tagen
sitzen wir in diesem Bahnhof fest."
"Die Wartsäle sind überfüllt
mit Kriegsgefangenen, Verletzten,
Typhuskranken und Toten."
"Am Nachmittag erhalten wir
endlich die Bewilligung,
in einen Zug zu steigen
und Richtung Norden zu fahren."
"Inzwischen dämmert es."
"Wir sehen die Steppe des Kuban
an uns vorbeiziehen."
"Brach und verlassen liegt sie da,
genauso wie wir sie
bei unserer Ankunft
vor 23 Jahren vorgefunden haben."
"24. Januar 1919."
"Mit dem Tageslicht
kommt wieder etwas Hoffnung auf."
"Wir fahren dem gefrorenen Fluss
Kuban entlang."
"Jedes Mal, wenn der Zug hält,
erstarren wir vor Schreck."
"Wir mussten die Reise unterbrechen
und eine Unterkunft suchen."
"Beide Enkelinnen sind krank."
"Die eine hat eine Bronchitis,
die andere eine Lungenentzündung."
"Wir wohnen in einem kleinen Hotel
beim Bahnhof."
"Es kommen laufend
neue Flüchtlinge an."
"Ganze Karawanen
von fliehenden Menschen."
"Einige
haben Hunderte von Kilometern
auf Viehwagen zurückgelegt."
"10. Februar 1919."
"Die Mädchen haben sich erholt
und wir setzen unsere Reise fort."
"Beim Anblick der Berge
waren wir ganz aufgeregt."
"Dahinter liegt Noworossijsk
und das Schwarze Meer."
"15. Februar 1919."
"Wir können es kaum glauben.
Wir können an Bord gehen."
"Nach zwei Tagen
laufen wir in Odessa ein,
dort warten wir auf die Weiterfahrt
und am 11. März
sind wir in Griechenland."
* Mystischer Gesang, schweres Atmen *
"Wir warten auf eine Möglichkeit,
um nach Italien zu kommen."
"Aber wenigstens
sind wir ausser Gefahr."
"Wir haben alles verloren,
aber wir sind in Sicherheit."
* Düstere Orgelmusik *
Michele Raggi
wird nicht mehr erleben,
wie sich seine Prognosen und Ängste
bewahrheiten.
Doch er sollte recht behalten.
Nach wenigen Jahren
kommt es in der ganzen Sowjetunion
zur Zwangskollektivierung.
Zahlreiche Bauern wehren sich dagegen
und werden entweder deportiert
oder getötet.
Die Lebensmittelproduktion
geht drastisch zurück,
was schliesslich
zur schrecklichen Hungersnot führt,
die sich bis heute im kollektiven
Gedächtnis der Menschen
im russischen Kaukasus
als schlimmstes Übel gehalten hat.
Sein Tod kam unerwartet.
Woran ist er gestorben?
Die Leute sagten vermutlich,
er sei an Herzschmerz gestorben.
Das hörte man oft in den Dörfern:
"Er ist an Herzschmerz gestorben."
Was bedeutet das, Herzschmerz?
Dass das Herz entzweibricht.
Und genau das geschieht ja
eigentlich bei einem Herzinfarkt,
wenn die Herzmuskeln
zerrissen werden.
Daher bin ich überzeugt, dass er
einen Herzinfarkt erlitten hat.
Und da dieser so unerwartet kam,
konnte die Familie nicht gleich
ein Grab für ihn finden.
Wo sollte er begraben werden?
Schliesslich
konnten sie den Grossvater
in das Familiengrab
der Familie Sardi legen.
Auf Wiedersehen, Urgrossvater,
ruhe in Frieden.